uh guys I just woke up 9 a.m. and I've
been scrolling on my phone for like 30
minutes it's super unproductive it
happens almost every morning I'm sick of
being a good boy full I honestly think
it's taking over my life so I just
checked and on average I spend 20 hours
on my phone a week 20 hours that's
almost an entire day wasted on my phone
that's insane
I recently saw a video that Emma
Chamberlain made where she didn't use
her phone for 24 hours and I was really
like inspired by that video I was like
wow I need to try that I think it's
getting really hard but I think it's
gonna do a lot of good for my life and
I'm gonna realize how much better life
is when you're not sitting on Instagram
and Facebook and just scrolling
mindlessly and distracting yourself the
entire time and baby see in 24 hours
we'll get through this distances good
sometimes taking breaks is important we
need to discover ourselves we need to
figure out ourselves you know I'm with
you so much and I'm growing and I'm
changing you I need time for myself I
need to know who I am without you see
you soon Oh before I put my phone away I
need to call my mom and let her know
that I'm a mister challenged because one
time I mom didn't hear from me for an
hour and she called the police
okay I was just gonna say I'm doing a 24
hours about my phone challenge forever
do okay I love you but didn't really
seem to care
she seemed like [ __ ] more important
things going on in her life but okay
here's what I'm gonna do
not only am I gonna put my phone away
I'm actually gonna cover it in a ton of
saran wrap right now I'm just gonna put
it in a cupboard I'm not gonna go to
that cupboard that cupboards the nono
zone okay sorry I don't have pants on
it's too early for pants okay let's
start the day what I do I have nothing
to do I give you so many things this
Henry Hart I'm gonna be so bored Wow
guys pooping without a phone is the
hardest thing I've ever done what are
you supposed to do you're just supposed
to focus on the poop coming out of your
butt okay so what I'm gonna do is make a
quick delicious breakfast this is
cooking with Eric Tubac they're just
literally gonna make a smoothie nice
boom a button on ah boom some mayonnaise
and some tuna almond butter and some
good old-fashioned oats
boom I'm just kidding about the
mayonnaise in the tuna I'm just being
silly
[Music]
this is like one of those inspirational
YouTube videos where it's like this is
my morning routine I waked up I brush my
teeth twenty five times I make myself
out the community that I stare out the
window for forty five minutes and think
about how incredible my life is and I
manifest manifest my future I think
about hey I'm gonna have a Lamborghini
today then I gonna buy a Lamborghini
mm-hmm this isn't that good this really
isn't that good my brain is confused so
I just laid in bed for about an hour
doing nothing just like a daydream Ian
thinking actually it was kind of nice it
was like unintentional meditation it's
getting late already so what I need to
do is I need to plan some activities I
need to do something I need to be
adventurous I need to experience life
outside of the screen you know what I
mean so I'm currently in San Francisco
I'm doing a play here it's called the
jungle at the current theater so I
haven't even had time to explore San
Francisco I haven't seen anything so
what I think I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
organize a little trip to a national
park that should make it a lot easier
because there's gonna be so much to do
and I'm not gonna need my phone so I'm
gonna organize a trip let's do this how
do I organize a trip without a phone
okay so the plan was I was gonna text my
cast mates and see who wanted to go to
the National Park but now I think I'm
gonna have to go to their apartment and
knock on their door and physically like
invite them it's so weird leaving the
house without the phone because I keep
like checking my pockets making sure
that I took my phone and then I realized
that I'm doing this chat
I don't have a phone anymore
going in an ancient elevator I had to
get led into the apartment by a stranger
and then I have to go into their
apartment to use their phone to call
this up because I forgot what apartment
she lives in so rough to a great start
I literally already forgot what
apartment she said she was in this is
what phones do to you your memory goes
super bad
10/10 not so text whoever you want I
don't care who you invite and we're
gonna go to a forest place yeah okay
what do you think of smartphones um I
think they're addictive and distracting
it's always in my hand it's like an
extension of me and that's a problem
this is Natalia this is Jonathan we're
splitting an uber but I don't have my
phone so that means I I can't pay right
Jonathan this is John by the way he's in
the play too but he's not coming on the
trip because he sucks because they
didn't invite me last it
we ended up inviting John yeah they
didn't want to invite my invited myself
[Music]
so we're meeting up with a San Francisco
local here Michelle and she's going to
take us to the National Park and give us
a little tour
[Music]
restaurant where yeah everyone gets the
same thing
oh yes John
[Music]
it's my phone right okay yeah Reno's
shalt have smartphone but stupid people
yeah we could go together you control
yourself you are empty first control
duloxetine second what you want me to
say an accident open your mercy look
them or even enemy will be free what are
the chances look at this
so what were you just saying I was just
saying that I don't have a smartphone I
never will because I see what it does to
people's minds so what do you have what
are you use instead
in 1998 2000 flip phone then keeping
alive that's what we were just talking
about when you're on a cell phone and
play a game like that or even social
media your brain produces dopamine which
is the neurotransmitter associated with
get this achievement look into this not
some of the top executives and IT and in
the field they do not let their children
to have a smartphone they're marking
those other kids you know they don't
keep it down kids
[Music]
Michelle is this a national park it
might be a state parks a park it's a
park its nature it's beautiful it smells
good time to rest the brain from social
media
[Music]
I'm not on my time making a picture
that's right
[Music]
Cass walking fast walking
[Music]
hi Rocky he's got blue eyes so I grab
some food real quick before the
performance and I feel so tempted to
call someone or text or school and now
that I'm alone it's kind of hard being
without a phone but it's nice because I
get a pay attention like to things
around me and things that are going on
but it is very it's like it feels like
an addiction like my body is craving
having a phone and being able to call
someone to do the show and I had to go
to the bathroom the bathroom is the only
challenging part of this video taking a
poop without a phone definitely the
hardest part okay guys so I just got
home from the show what a day I still
have not used my phone well I have had
the most incredible day and another
weird phone thing happened one of the
actors in the show missed his cue so he
didn't make it on stage in time because
he was on his phone and he was
distracted backstage this is all signs
that we should be using our phones less
I had so much time to think and and fuel
my emotions and like I just felt like I
was living more I don't know if I sound
crazy or how to explain it any better
but I just felt like I was seeing the
world I was noticing things I was
connecting with people feeling my day
with other activities so that I could
get endorphins then I get from scrolling
on Instagram from other things I'm very
tired what I'm going to do right now in
the shower go to bed and then wake up in
the morning and I guess check my phone
good morning guys I just woke up and I
realized I spent more than 24 hours
since I don't have a cell phone I didn't
set an alarm to wake up so I slept in
super late but I feel so refreshed oh my
but geez my hair my face everything I
usually tell me the dream and I had so
many vivid dreams today and I slept
really well
knocked out boom I don't feel the need
to check my phone the only reason I am
is because I need to for work because
everyone else is using these cell phones
now you have to - just stay updated
about it I'm gonna start using it way
less I'm gonna set up limiters I'm gonna
delete apps I'm just going to start
using my phone less and using it more as
a phone instead of as a toy
[Music]
Wow
I just spent so much time on the phone I
need this and most people need this but
I am going to limit my time on this
thing so you do what you want to do hope
you enjoy the video peace oh why did I
do that for real it's broken no no
[Music]